[Music]
there's this man who was born
in yunnan in china and was abducted
by a neighbor before being trafficked to
hunan province nearly 2000 kilometers
away right the man had spent a lifetime
trying to keep alive this memory of his
hometown
and now
this this dude has found his biological
mom using a hand-drawn map 33 years
after shut up whoa wait how where's the
hand drawer map come from did he [ __ ]
did it as a kid with crayons [ __ ] no he
he just kept the memory in his mind and
recently drew it out and it was able to
actually help determine where he was
from oh that's some like arya stark [ __ ]
you know like every night before she
goes to sleep like whoever whoever so
she like lists everybody that she's
gonna kill he's probably like every
night he can make a left at the river
they're across the river do you know did
he get kidnapped yeah he was kidnapped
so he was just remembering yeah so this
guy's 37 year old chinese man who was
abducted at the age of four he found his
biological mom drawing a map to his of
his home village was genius oh my god if
i got kidnapped at four i'm i'm a
different person that's that's it just
draw a dick
memory as a child
yeah
so zanjo on that helped police locate
where he was born and eventually helped
him reunite with his birth parents um
and he who does not even remember his
birth name was born in this uh the
yunnan province which is in southwestern
china
but when he was kidnapped by his
neighbor he was trafficked to the
central area of china which is why that
was 2000 kilometers away where he told
uh where he was told or when he was sold
to the family that
as a
kidnapped kid i mean like like like a
family just wanted to adopt a kid yeah i
guess so that's [ __ ] they just raised
them like because every time i think of
a kidnap situation i thought people just
wanted to [ __ ] [ __ ] children steal
them and use them for like slavery or
something i didn't think it would become
a warm loving family that just wants to
buy a kid nobody said warren loving we
don't know
from the black market yeah or was it
like additional farmhand help because
that's how i see like if they're being
bought and sold
i feel like it's usually not for the
kids
best you're thinking like a businessman
i think these people just wanted to
raise a kid and they maybe probably
couldn't have one they said they're
sterile they didn't have enough money
and they're like we only have a bag of
beets and they're like well i have a
child most optimistic steve's been all
day just saying like you know you to
think about that too yeah
this guy's name lee who has his own
family now provided a blood sample to
the authorities and began drawing what
he could remember of the home village
wait the chinese cops actually helped
him yeah he and he asked some clues
online about where it could be after you
drew it and the police eventually
narrowed it down to a village near the
mountainous city and you're not named
i don't even know how to pronounce it as
jiaotong
the authorities found a woman who was
probably the mother and the dna test
using the blood later confirmed that lee
was her son and the two uh met on
january 1st 2022. but they don't but
they don't get along yeah they hate each
other
there there goes the optimism
they don't see either eye on anything
and then one of them what if it wasn't
even a kidnapping she's like i'm so
happy to see you oh you found me son and
it was never reported so it wasn't a
kidnapping she just sold her kids yeah
he's like mom you have the nicest house
in the village this is incredible in
here
how'd you make your fortune oh
glad you asked
i think we did a similar article to this
last year uh which was interesting
because uh um he said he was inspired to
begin looking for his biological family
after learning about the high profile
stories of guo gan tang and sun hyung
two famous abduction cases that ended in
reunions last year in 2021 oh yeah i
realized i could not wait any longer
because my parents should be getting
older now i worried that when i figured
out where i'm from they might have
passed away and his father had passed
his 18th birthday his adopted family's
like hey
we could tell you some [ __ ]
watch at four how did how does he know
like hey can we see that map again
not totally sure it's like hey we bought
you dude it's crazy huh he is a father
um
now let me see let me see because he
said he's 37 that's crazy he remembers
being kidnapped and then he was awake
during the during the whole time and
then i don't remember any directions at
four years old
like bro i couldn't get back from my
house from costco last week
but also too it must have been a very
traumatic situation for him as a
four-year-old so i'm sure once again he
probably remembers everything yeah
that's the map
this is
his village yeah is that what he oh so
it wasn't directions to how he got out
it's just this is how i remember the
village he's got a 2000 kilometer
directional map
oh that's what i thought it's like this
whole remembered he left bread crumbs
and [ __ ] because i make a right here and
then i left here at this temple turn
right on ethan allen yeah eat the melon
costco the chinese ethan
allen oh yeah
i think i could have mapped not my not
my neighborhood but i could have mapped
out my block at four and like because i
remember
like all the different homes that i was
at
so like that little the home like the
like what do you call it like um the
multi-unit property that we first lived
in
um i was like up to up to three years
old there
and then like the the cul-de-sac that i
lived in until like i was six i i
remember like all the different houses
there but a whole village that's pretty
complex
that's true
that's a really good painting drawing
too he said it hurt when he later went
to school and read articles about family
gatherings but as time went by he became
immersed in work and later was busy
getting married and having his kids so
he didn't really think about it too much
um he didn't he did not mention what he
hoped would happen to the couple that
raised him recently the abducted
children have been reluctant to
prosecute parents who raised them as
they often have a good relationship with
the family that they grew up so it was
like a family that was just like i want
kids
yeah
one guy was like i could get one for a
district yeah there's a kid's plug in
the village yeah
yeah you want some kids
just in a coat
well i feel like they they've been there
photos in china they buy kids like farm
animals like hey anyone want a golden
retriever like you know you go to the
[ __ ] parking lot the chinese dude has
like a golden retriever and he goes you
want a puppy
[ __ ] mexican dude puts out a [ __ ]
palette cart we have puppies that's how
downtown la is now uh fashion district
they have all kinds of cool dogs that's
how i got my dog my chihuahua yeah yeah
it was in the back of a home depot and
riverside dude had a bunch of childs
they look [ __ ] super malnourished uh
the the parents were chained up just
looking like super dead and he was just
holding this cute little dog and i was
like what are you doing man
i was telling you what was
that damn and then i was like how much
was it well the thing is uh he was on
for 150
what and then um but me i'm a very i'm a
very stories guy i was like selling
dodger tickets at the time i was doing
like marketing for them and i was and i
saw a dodger sticker on the back of his
truck and i was like are you a dodger
fan he's like yeah why and i was like
dude this be a sick story i was like
trade your tickets for this dog right
he's like how much did i like show them
like thing so we trade and i'm like [ __ ]
yeah sick story and then like 20 minutes
later i'm calling my sister in total
regret and panic because i'm like i have
a [ __ ] chihuahua in the back of my
car i don't know what i just did and why
but i [ __ ] have a dog now and
i haven't [ __ ] traded dogs for dodger
tickets yeah and that's why i named it
dodgers like cars for kids
easy dude don't [ __ ] get that jingle
on my head
easy man
they say as of november more than 8 300
children who went missing over previous
decades have been found under an
initiative called tuan yuan
which
that sucks because 83 children 8 300
children
who have been found means there's
probably like tens of thousands of
you know what children mean like that's
gotta be crazy
damn dude kids man
can't be selling kids can you tell the
kids let's start with that yeah i mean i
guess it's good stuff if you're in the
market for kids right like
like if you're out there and you're just
like i can't care i'm a kid but i want a
kid like this family right and i'll be
one of the good kid buyers like i'll
raise them right i'll be one of the good
ones you know like i'm not like a kid
toucher like i'm the only touching is
hugging right and loving in in a in a
family way right so like this family and
then like but like yeah i still don't
understand why they think it's okay to
buy it from a
underground kids circuit just from a guy
yeah it's like yo you got any kids like
i got a [ __ ] real cute boy for you
you know i was like
like why don't they just go don't they
have adoption centers in china don't
they have or maybe that's what it is
like in my head i'm like what if they
went to an orphanage or adoption place
and they were like
none of these ones is going to work and
then they have like a special guy that
goes out and gets you the one that you
ideally specialist yeah because they're
like a car broker yeah like a bounty
hunter yeah and he'll go what are you
looking for i don't know some
four-year-old whatever and they're like
let me call someone and see if we have
some someone in something in the back
let me check my stock
yeah it could because they maybe they
just don't know any bigger they just
give you profiles like hair color it's
like a [ __ ] avatar that you're
building on nintendo wii when somebody
takes that information just drives
around looking for something that fits
the description like looking more from
1995 this row of kids is like obviously
no one's gonna adopt them and then they
just always go out and get the one
but they are used though
that's my thing about it because i would
want it to be like actually from the
birth canal let's go yeah oh yeah brand
new one
but maybe
you know not everyone can afford a new
car a new house so maybe somebody has to
get a refurbished kid like a discount
like a poncho
bravia
yeah it works yeah yeah it's a poncho
yellow sticker on it and then you rip
off the sticker and it still has the
smudge and you're like well whatever
it's like kid bay right and there's
ratings like like new
you know new new mint condition
that one's expensive those are really
expensive mid condition kit yes
some have salvaged title salvage title
broken hearted how much do you think
this kid was sold for
oh [ __ ] dollar wise was it a sale like
that's what it was 37 something years
ago too
it was probably cheap yeah make sure you
account for inflation
what if you drop your kid on your way
out of the store
and it comes back and you're like yo
this kid got a [ __ ] head injury like
how you dropped your cold stone yeah
you're like sir come on i didn't even
get to my car with this thing can we
just like you know yeah
scoop me out another one please cause
this guy bumped into me and i dropped
like you keep that one it's on the house
there's another one oh okay okay that's
better on the house yeah okay because if
i was that family trying to trying to
get some kids i'd be like dude what the
[ __ ] where did you get this dude
that's crazy right like even you ask
like wait where's what are you doing
here with the chihuahuas like you had
the decency to ask in question i gave
you 50 off how do you get the kid to not
talk about
what happened
uh don't tell the kid anything i'll give
you 25 percent
that's true because a four-year-old's
gonna be like i want to see my mommy
yeah
are you the yeah what are you gonna say
not a new kid i am your mommy now like
the [ __ ] that's probably what they say
that that's that's what blows my mind is
this family they went on with it and
they're okay with that unless they like
jacked him from a a family so insanely
poor that his education is that low that
he can't even articulate he was
kidnapped
you know it could be oh yeah four years
old i kidnapped the puppy yeah i mean we
already know we all kidnapped the puppy
or their parents right and when it comes
home what does it do the first night
cries like a [ __ ] yeah and i'm
pretty damn sure a kidnapped kid who's
smarter than the puppy is gonna do the
same [ __ ] kidnap the puppy dude yeah
same thing though right yeah they'll cry
don't cry until they get comfortable
because there's no nothing else to do
because no matter what they can't take
care of themselves so the second they
recognize uh the new almost central
authority that feeds them that they have
to rely on that's the relationship you
want something funny about well i guess
this isn't funny but about puppies on
craigslist now you know how they do it
now where they because it's illegal to
sell
puppies
like on offer up yeah really yeah yeah
the way they do it now is they tell you
they're selling something else and they
just put a puppy next to it yeah oh like
like tennis racket and then there's like
a golden retriever shitload of puppies
next to that tennis racket and then they
know you're going to ask about it how
come you can't do that anymore like the
penny's favorite they're breeding they
don't want people to just make dogs to
sell them because there's some weird
[ __ ] that goes on with that yeah the
dogs come out all [ __ ] x-men and [ __ ]
yeah that's great yeah because the
second dog i got um we called the house
right and then my parents you know
during the time they have a thick ass
accent whatever and then like when we
got there
they're asking these weird questions and
i was just playing with the dogs they're
like oh thank god it's a family yeah we
were just scared that you guys were
going to buy them for the restaurants
and stuff and
whoa
[ __ ]
because during that time they were
reporting how
asian restaurants were [ __ ] serving
dogs
so then this family so they bought into
that [ __ ] thing yeah and it was just
on cnn and [ __ ] and we were being judged
by this like straight up like
white trash trailer [ __ ] like
straight up they were like hella
[ __ ] up cars in the back and all these
junkyard dogs were coming out and they
were just trying to protect their dogs
they're like oh thank god it's a family
yeah you know with everything going on
we just didn't know
and then yeah oh my god you know i was
just like and you're like i'm not gonna
eat this until it gets bigger
so that's how they file it if you go on
offer up you'll see it say dog cage or
puppy food so that when you write dog or
puppy you'll still get the hit and it'll
be it'll show like a little [ __ ]
already open bag of pedigree who's gonna
[ __ ] buy that but there's a puppy
right next to it and i'll just say
inquire ask ask inquire ask but don't
you guys remember on the back of all the
like panty savers all the all the
craigslist or whatever right hella
people are just giving out free dogs
yeah yeah yeah all the time free dog
free dogs cause there's like unexpected
litters
yeah we gotta get rid of them yeah i
remember that in the paper all the time
too as a kid
always free animals somewhere yeah too
bad they don't do that anymore with kids
because they did in the great depression
oh they gave away freaky oh because they
feed my kids because they couldn't yeah
so they'll be though there's pictures of
like uh ladies outside with like three
four kids and they have a poster that
they made like like one of those like
protest posters yeah
free kids
yeah yeah
i mean are kids really free though
that's true
they cost lots of money dude it's a
little misleading especially they
[ __ ] like spiderman and [ __ ] [ __ ] man
or they're like peta and they're like
they're part of the free kids movement
but all the kids kept on getting jacked
and like what the [ __ ] we're trying to
try to put this message out there
to free the kids people don't get it
[Music]
uh
[Music]